[Music]
so alex is here hey what's up alex
[Applause]
what's up obviously we brought this
article up for you because we heard
through the grapevine this is what you
believe
he likes beating women wow
people
hey nice with an open hand right
specifically people still strongly
believe will smith's slap on chris rock
at the oscars was staged how do you feel
about that i feel that that is the
correct statement to be made i feel like
it was fake
and youtube was fake there's more stuff
coming out now that i'm just like more
stuff huh i have to say i do have to say
why did it look why did it look like
hamlet
yeah
he's such an actor yeah dude and then
when he walked away he was like he's
like yeah
when he did it his feet weren't like
this and stuff i was like you all
judging the boy's stance right there
dude he was in front of like a hundred
million people well not that many more
50 million people and then chris rock's
laughing and he's like leaning forward
and he's like
i'm like you know what it is they're
natural performers dude when they get on
that stage they just can't help but to
perform that's what i think it is oh no
after it happened i saw a picture
who knows if it's real or not nick
thinks it's fake but there's like a pad
on chris rock's face that they look like
they put makeup on over it trying to
hide it
and i'm like well and it's on the i'll
run the wrong side
you got it here
this is the pad supposed to do just to
absorb impact it's probably like a the
gauze path oh that's what it is what i'm
saying but because like the slap didn't
even sound like
you know it sounded like
i was just like yeah i don't buy this
[ __ ] stay on
now there's like videos of like jada
right after he slaps her he's all she's
all laughing and [ __ ] and then it gets
back over there i'm just like let's go
through all the theories because i
believe it too i feel like there's
something fishy going on because
that guy is way too like controlled and
professional to do something so
impulsive dude he was standing up for
his wife man he had to stand up for his
wife
she got insulted on the grand married
table we need to get to the merry table
that's that but but that's one of the
theories too is that he's being
controlled under with from jada but i
want to go through all of them because
so um i had this like i've been talking
about every [ __ ] day with my girl for
like since it happened right so she
believes that it's not constructed like
he just it she believes the theory i
think that um he's in a very toxic
relationship with jada and that he got
cut yeah he basically like on facebook
there's that do you guys you guys saw
that was that name august you guys saw
that he was laughing right and then
i mean it could be a different angle or
cut cut weird or whatever but he was in
a [ __ ] gut over a gi jane two joke
too and then when you look back
he's like jada's not laughing he's
looking straight and then that thing
happens so
um yeah so she thinks that you know he's
in a very toxic relationship and then
that you know he was basically like
he's under her thumb like it's like now
it's like oh i gotta prove something and
he's been looking
like a [ __ ] in the media so he probably
had to feel like i had to do something
about that card back or something such a
general statement but i love it but it's
kind of true diagnosis
everybody's been feeling bad for him
it's that show that she's on red table
talk and she's talking about getting
[ __ ] down by like a million dudes it
and she also says like she's bored of
will smith she's like i don't like being
in a relationship it was so [ __ ] mean
i was like that is not a loving
relationship dude and on top of that um
do you remember when she was talking
about tupac yeah how she was like that
was the only man i loved or whatever i'm
quoting it wrong but then no that's what
she said basically like tupac oh tupac i
got will but tupac that's basically what
it was like right in front of him too i
saw a meme where it's it was like her
leaning in she was like thank you tupac
would have shot him but a slap is good
enough i was just like oh i saw that was
a good meme that was really good i
enjoyed it to be honest this out right
here shows that the fake hand and the
cheek pad was actually debunked in
further proof no but what website are
you getting this office
we're going to debunk the site who's the
host buddy who's the host all right you
stay on your side of the table you can't
look at the computer dude don't look at
the computer over here all right not
allowed here but no the point is uh you
know that meme that was being passed
around in 8k footage you see this cheek
pad you know on chris rock's face but
then when he gets slapped you see the
other photos post slappage there's no
cheek pad what about that one that's
because they did the makeup good on this
side but not on this side here i'll show
you let me ask you this how about this
what about that where's the cheek pad
yeah see but you see the cheek pad on
the inside see what like was it right
though do you guys agree with it do you
guys just smacking the dude yeah
smacking the dude for telling the joke
on the i'm always for violence okay
i think it's hilarious this is hard for
me especially when a big dude slaps the
[ __ ] out of a little dude i think it's
hilarious you like the bullying aspect
let's just slap everybody yeah it's
worse
it's all about equality slap kids slap
women slap everybody minorities let's go
free for all right i was having this
conversation too uh because loki uh i
was entertained by it yeah but there was
an immediate like understanding is like
oh he should not have done that but i
also think it's because of the context
of the place right it's like when you
think about like the oscars regardless
of the ratings or whatever the [ __ ] it
is it's like this new age kind of um you
know modern society version everybody
gets dressed up in tuxes this red
carpets is a dress it's like very almost
like an old school ball right and when
you go to like an old school ball like
let's say old english type [ __ ] there's
like an etiquette where even if somebody
does some sort of like
scandal or like says something kind of
like you know
malicious or whatever like that is like
the highest news everybody gathers
exactly so [ __ ] duels and [ __ ] too
yeah yeah but you know let's go outside
i'm gonna slap you but afterwards i'm
gonna shoot you like like he can't like
that's not a duel right there call out
will smith would have to go up take out
his gloves slap him throw it on the
floor spit and then be like later yeah
versus doing the full-on hit right there
you know what i'm saying so i feel like
the context of the space made it so
clear like you can't do that there
you could do that afterwards
i actually thought it made him look more
like a [ __ ] for real because it's like
you can't control your emotions i
thought he was better than that i
thought you know
and on top of that it's like pull him
aside and talk to him like hey man come
on that joke went too far it was bad
what's up man and then i'm sure chris
could have been like oh sorry dude like
but uh make a public display out of it
over a joke like that what the hell's
going on in his life where he could get
triggered that easily especially people
at that level i feel like they go
through so much they have to hold back
then they're controlled like they have
their publicist they have their team
everything that they say some of these
guys don't even have their [ __ ] login
accounts to their twitter except trump
but you know what i mean like but they
also get away with the [ __ ] time
for will smith to go up to chris rock
and hit him
and slap him on the face on national tv
in front of 80 million people that just
says he doesn't think anyone's gonna
[ __ ] with him and you know the oscars
asked them to leave and then he said no
yeah anything he stayed and then he
stayed and won a statue so he was right
but also although too it's like
everybody at the oscars gets roasted
yeah
well that's why they bring comedians to
host it if you know what's going to
happen gi james ii look bro whatever it
was
and it's an old reference i don't think
jada looks good with the bald head i
think she looks great with the bald head
why she why is she upset about this she
looks great
jj was hot by the way yeah i know right
big deal
we were we were big fans of gij yeah
big fans one arm push-ups remember
that's oh yeah i can imagine the
craziness of like the emotional flair
that may have been received like if you
did you know look over at your wife and
she's like maybe holding back tears or
really insulted by something that she's
been struggling with i can understand
the [ __ ] fire he had dude he was like
hey jada you're a [ __ ] all right so uh
[Laughter]
yeah that would be different yeah that
would feel like
hey jada you right here you are a [ __ ]
he would actually uh protect her he
would actually protect jada by telling
her
yo like chill out that level of a joke
is not something to be upset by but then
if you want me to [ __ ] [ __ ] up a dude
for that joke that's gonna make both of
us look bad what if that's the part we
didn't see on camera it's like haha
she's like looking at him like go [ __ ]
him up that's what i want to see i want
to see what happened in between him
laughing and then her role yeah because
it's so fast they're immediate he's
busting up laughing and then the next
like second he's walking up on stage
chris thought he was doing a bit yeah
all right well here goes will what's
will gonna do now
my man
he ate it pretty well though plus he
he's feeding the trolls big time because
i don't know if you guys i mean
obviously everyone's seen the memes by
now it's pretty crazy like i saw one
that's like jada likes to get her hair
pulled but she has no hair and they put
a plunger on top of her head
and they're yanking on it and i was like
that's pretty great
did you make that one up but he opened i
saw him i saw me
he was on the same one
that's so good
everyone's coming after him now
everybody well dude if comedy central
came out immediately it was like we're
doing a roast with jd pink and smith
we're all watching oh my god and
comedians are going to show up in body
armor and we'll have will there let's
[ __ ] go your body armor
bring it it'll be so good you'll be the
sickest [ __ ] will slap everybody wow do
you know do you guys feel like the only
reason why he went up there and slapped
chris rock was because he felt in his
mind that like oh i could sun him real
quick like i'm the alpha yeah like if it
was the rock hosting he wouldn't have
done that [ __ ] yeah no you think samuel
jackson was saying the joke do you think
he would have won up there when you when
you hit a person that that can't defend
themselves because of like publicly like
you know it's like you're on stage right
like chris is gonna his career he looks
like the better man tonight oh hell yeah
he handled it very well also he's a
smaller dude and then for me it just
feels wrong like it's like hitting kids
or like hitting women or like i don't
know it's not it's not total
it tickled a little it's just funny that
you compared like slapping chris rock to
like a small child
but the size difference dude that's
literally like the wrong big dude yeah
he ate it pretty well too i feel i would
imagine will smith has a very large hand
i would also imagine that if it was like
kevin hart instead of chris rock kevin
hart would have came back at him
oh for sure even though he's smaller
yeah i think he would have liked done
something yeah but i feel like also too
like i think he was genuinely so shocked
by the moment yeah yeah he was
trying to process it like that
i think like you were saying like chris
rock looks good in this situation yeah
he does yeah he did it and then he just
sat there and kind of like laughed a
little bit and like was shocked he
continued his job he made a joke too did
you see that he got his shows all sold
out
like dude his ticket says like 300
something dollars like the average price
and they gave him a five-minute standing
ovation at his first comedy show yeah
so uh i think that chris rock paid will
smith to slap him that's why he had the
cheek pad on just so his tickets also go
up because his ticket sales were so
let's go into those theories man because
it's really good i already had a show
what do you mean well he had a stand-up
tour going on
so he already had his first show and he
didn't talk yeah he just had his first
show he didn't talk about he uh he had
like a four to five minute standing
ovation and like to the point where he
apparently got like really emotional
nearly teared up then he said like stuff
to be said i'll joke about it another
time something serious some funny he
said he's put some like processing yeah
but today i just came here to tell some
jokes because i i think it's a publicity
stunt too but i'm still like like
piecing all the stuff of motive because
we have to look at motive right some
people believe that it's just pure
impulse it's too reckless for it to be a
publicity i think i think that you think
that it's actually just a impulsive move
i think that yeah he was in the moment
because of [ __ ] that he's dealing with
personally yeah he's just he's just had
to be a [ __ ] boy about it he couldn't
take the joke and uh and he's like that
was [ __ ] up that you did this gig
but did you see the part where she was
laughing yeah exactly do you think that
theory of uh jada actually like
controlling will i think that that's a
little egregious i think it's like it's
like he's sitting there and he's already
you know kind of a cuckold it's fine and
then and then she's she like he's
laughing at the joke and then she she
she sees him laughing at the joke she's
she's feeling bad about the joke and
he's like i'm going to do something
about this [ __ ] right now i'll prove my
[ __ ] manhood of this because everyone
thinks i'm up yeah watch me not be a
[ __ ] and do this little shakespeare
slap
good lord dude
so
he imagined he went up there and did the
stunner
and chris walker crack two beers
they always bounce
that would have been way more manly like
a switch in music
sidekick to the face cause i am trying
to figure out who wins when they do that
too because
um a
point that um hannah brought up was that
if it was a publicity stunt and because
one of the theories that i brought up
was well um
oscar's been [ __ ] sucking for the
last they're really boring right like as
in ratings like and in popularity and
it's just dwindling like crazy and so
maybe they're doing a desperate move
to get eyes back on it because now
everyone's [ __ ] talking about it no
one talked about it last year no one
knew that the oscars were even happening
unless
because of will slap that's why people
knew right
but then but then a good point was made
where it's like if hollywood did
construct this right they wouldn't put
two black guys up there to do that it
would probably be like like a
transgender white person smacking like a
transgender black person or some [ __ ]
like or like i don't know be some kind
of
straight white male beating up a black
man or something right like it's gonna
be that narrative
but on top of that it's like
who wins that's where i got to figure
out but then i started digging and
there's a lot of [ __ ] wild weird uh
theories and one of them that i really
like is pfizer is on its third try
oh my god i saw this
treatments
so i'm like did so are they
are they assuming that pfizer paid out
will
and and will and [ __ ] chris rock
millions to do this so they could bring
alopecia to the [ __ ] world honestly
nobody ever talks about it until this
incident i hope the media is happy that
they lie to us so much that now joe
thinks the [ __ ] it's an alopecia ad it's
big pharma dude
[Laughter]
that was one of the wildest ones i saw
alopecia
the reason why will slapped chris rock
was pfizer we uncovered something dude
we uncovered that we can't imagine chris
like wanting or accepting money like at
the level they're already in to slap
each other
maybe chris i feel like chris ain't like
at that level like that will smith's
back but they both have like a sense of
pride yeah i think he's just quiet he's
like the goat but isn't will like
everyone nobody even knows you want a
[ __ ] oscar right everyone's just
talking about how he's doing what about
the speech how'd you guys feel about the
speech i didn't even watch it i didn't
watch it thank you so much speech like
that was kind of you know you know
what's my conspiracy thought like do you
think at the last second after you got
after chris got slapped they switched
who wins because they wanted him to have
a speech
you know well i think they knew he was
going to win that's why they left oh
that's what i let him say and see the
movie that he won for king something
king that's what that's what made me
like suss i'm like that was kind of like
weird
a lot of things don't make sense though
right because it's like there's a lot of
reason why they would like this
but then
but then how does will win out of this
exactly right why would he agree to this
i think he thought he was going to win i
think in his mind he's like dude i'm
killing it because after like he slapped
him in the face there was a sense of
like
accomplishment that i that i got from
him yeah has uh has he won an oscar
because what if okay here's another one
that i could widely come up with if the
oscars said
i'll give you an oscar if you [ __ ] do
this for us
i'll give you an oscar oscar association
they're conniving dude there's always
like to earn one and just go with it
uh yeah votes are in but you know dude
you want the awesome set them up where
they're like all right you're gonna
you're gonna slap chris he's gonna block
it you're gonna do this awesome choreo
thing it'll be funny i think chris is
not in on it at all
they just totally set him up and you
gotta really sell it
to like the impractical jokers oh and it
was like all right now go slap chris
rock in the face and then it's a picture
of him slapping him and then all of them
laughing just busting up
i just hope that's the thing too because
like there's a comedy element to this
and i just hope that all comedians now
when they're about to do a hair joke as
somebody who suffers from hair [ __ ]
myself they think twice
there could be hell coming your way in
the form of this
shakespeare hair roasts now
it does pose the question though of like
who was in the right because some people
actually believe oh will went too far
there's certain things you don't believe
you shouldn't joke about that and and
it's okay he was defending his woman and
then other people are just like yo it's
a joke like no one should ever get beat
over a joke well and there's people
pulling up uh i guess there's a clip of
him on like
some old show and he's doing an alopecia
or he's doing a bald bit about somebody
who suffers from alopecia so some people
are like see wilson is a hypocrite it's
like dude he is this is he's a hypocrite
he saw
that's the amazing thing about the
internet he saw his wife was pissed and
he's like
i gotta do something about this [ __ ] and
it was just the wrong place wrong time
wrong person my last thing is like why
slap him and then walk away and then
scream at him too
like you know what i'm saying like why
not slap him and then be like yo keep my
name my wife's name at your [ __ ]
mouth like right there in front of him
he slaps him walks all the way back to
his chair sits down it's like keep my
wife's name out your mouth oh the
staging's too too perfect
yeah i think and will smith's a good
actor so like if they were going to
choose somebody to do this he's the best
actor yeah yeah he's really good at
christmas
you know what i'm saying so that's that
was very believable well in his speech i
felt like is this acting or is this
genuine because he you know he's
producing these tears and i'm like i
don't know i don't know i don't know
where you stand on this do you think
it's legit when uh when the comedians
were saying now
like it it's a threat to comedy where
like people just walk up and slap
whoever's doing stand up i get what
they're saying but uh like i said the
the slap was so like
i don't know dude everyone's acting like
will smith nuked the stage and i'm like
did anybody see it if i could do jokes
like that and get hit like that i'd keep
doing the jokes because there's no
consequence like it's just like my mom
[ __ ] me up harder than that
last night and he i'm sure he's gonna
have this for a while now but he had
like a crazy heckler they had to kick
him out they had to like pepper spray
this guy what that bad
[Music]
they bought tickets just to heckle him
and talk [ __ ] saw it on um abc7 they
posted it and this guy was getting
kicked out of the show i guess he was
heckling him really bad they had to
pepper spray this guy and handcuff him
and everything that kind of [ __ ] happens
all the time though too so people are
going to take that now and go see what
will smith started and now will there's
a chain reaction people are all going to
start doing like listening to will smith
and attacking comedians i don't believe
that [ __ ] then pfizer
all for the alopecia push i wish i wish
people would all bring like sticky hands
to like the chris rock shows and just
try to get him
come let me ask you guys this genuine
question
if if will smith is in the room or and
jada pinkett smith is in the room would
you do a jada joke
like with confidence after seeing what
you saw with chris where if we're
um at the same level of celebrity um
because i'm not first like fanboy
because then if i'm fanboying then i
just be like starstruck but if if i was
in chris's shoes and we're just like on
stage
yeah it's funny yeah are you afraid of
will smith [ __ ] no i'm afraid of jada
though i don't think will smith put the
fear out there at all dude yeah no no he
just seems like a really nice guy but
after he slapped chris rock i was like i
don't know but dude imagine you
shakespeare slap a guy and then you get
up on stage and you [ __ ] cry about it
afterwards and talk for like eight
minutes and everyone's like dude i'm i
think this will smith's guy is hard as
[ __ ]
he got the street cred
in the oscars oh no one messing with
that's what i'm reading i'm reading like
tom sagar and all these all these
comedians are what i like a lot they're
all talking about how this is attacking
all of comedy right now i'm like
bro this is not the 911 economy
this is just residual from the
millennium
this is like when tom cruise like was
getting interviewed by that guy he gets
splashed with water he's like why the
[ __ ]
yeah it's the equivalent of that yeah
when he grabs and goes why would you do
that
this is exactly
like
why would you do that he's so deliberate
too he's like why would you do that i'm
a nice person
you gotta get nervous watching the video
i do my own stunts is that what this is
about i do my own stunts
it is very a kid today
[Music]